[Music]
mariah
is starting off this hour in harrisburg
pennsylvania
hi mariah how are you i'm good dave how
are you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so uh
one thing that i really want to
celebrate is i paid off my student loans
um two days ago yay so
yeah that's one big milestone of my life
and
i still have some debt left i still have
a car loan and
my parents have been gracious enough
towards me that they've allowed me to
stay at home
with them the freeway they can allow me
to pay off my debt
so they've been really gracious with me
with that
so uh both my parents know how
determined i am to pay off my car
loan too and um i have left as
like that's what i have left so i'll
make it short for you
um so uh
it's only fair to them that i help them
with utilities
and electric since i'm still living at
home and
me and my mother have come to that
agreement and that's perfectly
acceptable
because i'm still living under their
roof um
one thing i'm not comfortable with is
that
she wants to charge me rent which is
fair but
the stipend is that she will hold on to
that money for me
in her savings account and she won't let
me put that in my savings account
so i feel like there's a trust issue
there
per se like she doesn't trust me with my
own money
and she wants to help me out in a sense
of
saving it for the future but
i'm 27 years old 27
what do you make a year i make about 30
grand
working two jobs so i work 40 hours a
week at my other job and i put in about
20 hours with my part-time job so
you know i maria learning you're 27
you know my i'm kind of split so let me
say this on the flip side
my father did did the exact same thing
that
your mother is doing um uh but i was 20.
you know i was 19 20 maybe 21 around
that time
um he actually i i paid him 250
a month and by the time i moved out he
actually gave that all back to me and
some
uh to start my life off but let me ask
you a question i want you to be honest
with us
should your mom be able to trust you
like are you being
a good steward with your money i
am yeah she wants to play a game
where she's the landlord and at the end
of the game she gives me all that money
from
the base rent that i've saved up over
and i don't think that's say that i've
moved out so maria i think you got to
look at that differently that's not a
game that's i think that's your mother
trying to help you become a young adult
and if you've never paid rent before you
you do need to know how to do that so i
would definitely take the word game out
of it
out of you out of your head and say okay
cool let me just pay my mom rent
move on about your life get out of debt
and do everything um
and then just accept the fact that your
mom is just trying to help you mature
help you get ready for real life because
i'm pretty sure her rent is nowhere near
what rent is actually going to be but i
would definitely say eventually
uh i would try out honestly if i was you
and dave may disagree with this
but at 27 i'm i'm looking at how do i
get out of the house even if i do have
some debt on the table yeah you need to
be going
you need to be gone in three months yeah
i didn't know
i'm gonna move out kiddo okay
you're 20 you're 27 years old it's time
to move out
get get your job working get get your
budget on an apartment figure out how
it's going to work
tell mom i got about three months to get
my act together the rest of the way
and um uh it's time for you to move out
you're you're
uh this is emotionally
treating someone like they're 18 17 19
years old or whatever and you're
27 yeah okay so yeah you need to move
on and your mom's trying to be sweet
she's trying to be helpful but it's time
for you to take that next big girl step
and uh it'll change your life it'll be
good for you